one good morning Millennials welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday it is
hump day so very appropriately we are
sitting here with bright Stripes Jackson
Claude the four of us are going to be
humping all throughout the day I hope
your day looks something like that
honestly the four of us are back
together it's been I can't even tell you
how long since both Bryce and Strikes
were on camera with the two of us and
the gang is back together nature is
healed nature is healed duh
um maybe that's a really good segue to
one of the things we wanted to talk
about at the beginning of today's
episode healed healed come on Jackie
healed healed
[Music]
healed
I don't know yourselves yourselves oh
wow we're gonna just jump right well I
thought it was like a mutual like nod it
was a far-reaching segue but I
appreciate the segue I actually don't
think it was far-reaching at all like I
was shocked you didn't know what I was
talking about yeah sorry I really didn't
know we will address that let's just
finish with our introduction before we
get into the controversy yeah um another
day another controversy happy Wednesday
we have a great show for you today
because we have your toasters as stated
we will be addressing unburdening
yourselves we will we will be addressing
the controversy three we watch the tell
me lies finale finale last night and
like I'm so glad that we did because I
have so many thoughts yeah
I can't believe that it's not a limited
series I am like annoyed and that we're
waiting for season two to be greenlit
yes giving Society yeah I think I
actually have to read the book because
because you're so curious because I'm so
curious before we dropped an amazing
patreon episode last night so late last
night Claude and I came to the studio We
snuck on up here with our little
Halloween candy it was toast after dark
it was totes after dark even the
lighting's different were no makeup it
was frightening we posted video and
audio and it was the part two of the
general q a which was questions for me
and it was just a grand old time yeah
and if you're not already a patron let
me tell you what we have on offer for
you this month plus everything else
we've done over the last four years
which includes our highlights like the
great chili cook-off Jackie learning how
to drive the Vlog the mukbang Vlog like
every time we took a trip Stagecoach
coach Coachella it's all there every
podcast we've answered really every
question but this month we had Claudia
interviewing me which was last night uh
last week I interviewed Claudia with all
the questions that you guys have for her
we had our Taylor Swift kickoff attempt
which was great the first episode this
month was I don't know
was it studying for the permit
for the permit test was it I think so
we're getting Jackie ready to get her
license like we're really covering all
of our bases on patreon and if you are a
patreon member you also get access to
the pre-sale for my shows which today we
launched two shows in New York that
we're going to be filming for a special
and a show in Delaware that only patreon
girlies get access to so separately a
show in Delaware and separately a show
in Delaware the one in Delaware is not
being taped I was like trying to really
find a way to announce all three shows
without making it seem like the one in
Delaware was being taped and no matter
how many ways I typed it like it was
still confusing it's still misleading so
let me just say right now like Delaware
is gonna be amazing and it will not be
recorded
but that's not a reason not to go I
couldn't agree more yeah
um so there's really no reason that you
shouldn't join patreon it's just a great
time for the patrons plus Claudia and I
are gonna bang some content while she's
here some really fun episodes for the
month of November so
yeah patreon.com the toast now let's
dive into the controversy so we're going
on quite a few Mondays where we have not
done our you know signature segment
unburden yourselves
um and a lot of people after this week's
episode were like writing in the
comments and on Facebook first there had
been YouTube comments did I miss
something what happened to unburdened
and yes you are not you haven't missed
anything Jackie and I haven't done it in
a few weeks at first it was because
Monday has recently became like such
long episodes for us we had House of the
Dragon recap and then like just the
weekend recap and we would have been
going on like two hour episodes and
actually our memory card really could
only sustain a 90 minute episode that is
the longest we can do daily and I think
that's like that's enough you know yeah
um so that was part of the reason and I
think also Jackie and I were feeling
like a little uninspired by the segment
I feel like you were because you felt
like it was very similar to Deer
toasters but yeah I I like unburning
yourselves I don't think unburning
yourselves is is over I just think we
went on Hiatus because the last few
Mondays were really jam-packed and then
we didn't even realize we weren't doing
it and neither of us missed it but now
that I'm seeing that there's so much
fanfare for it I guess this has been a
really great learning moment because I
didn't realize how much you guys loved
it and now with everyone shouting out
for it it makes me feel like I want to
do it again for me fundamentally like
there is a fundamental issue with the
segment in the sense that it either
really is too similar to Deer toasters
or we're just talking about poop which
is fun every couple of weeks but like
once a week like a 20 minute segment on
duty like it's not that fun so what do
we want to be but we can curate better
the ones that we choose we just we also
don't get great submissions like oh not
you blaming the audience no a lot of the
submissions are asking for advice which
is dear toaster yeah or we just feel
compelled to give advice but I don't
think we should give up but I'm burning
yourselves because it's so great it's so
fun to say and people do need to
unburden themselves like let's get back
to what the original intent was which
was to take that burden off of people
who like have a
anxiety and a pit after the weekend okay
like feel free to fill up the inbox
unburdenyourselves at gmail.com
um
I'm not willing to let it go either but
I do think changes need to be made
okay that's just my my take on the
situation I don't disagree but I
appreciate the outpouring of fanfare and
love and support for unburdening
yourselves and now that house of the
Dragon is over true we do kind of have
the space for it we do have I think it's
perfect timing yes so life is all about
timing you guys in the the true thing
that the truth
everything speaking of timing at this
time tomorrow Thursday 10 a.m eastern
time our sorority crewnecks will have
launched relaunched restocked on
shopmorningtoast.com we are restocking
our iconic iconic sorority sweaters that
everyone has been asking us to restock
for quite some time we finally did it
pictures are will be up on our Instagram
if you have any questions feel free to
drop a DM drop a comment it's a big week
here at the morning shows it's kind of
just like
we're also attempting to drop something
else tomorrow that we it was a really
quick turnaround oh yeah it was a little
special treat so keep your eyes peeled
on our Instagram hopefully we'll be able
to announce it today and that we're able
to do it in time for tomorrow's like an
idea that we had this week so yeah a
little something for the moment it's a
little something for The Mamas and I'm
really excited about that yeah I forgot
about that good call so again just like
like it's exhausting but Somebody's
gotta do it I mean look at these strikes
Brethren they're exhausted they're
exhausted I'm so glad to be podcasting
with them yet again we do have deer
toasters today which really is like one
of my favorite things to do just
interesting to see what goes on in
people's lives you know yeah
what's my favorite I'm like nosy we
don't have that many segments that's
that was part of the reason why we
birthed unburdened yourselves yeah I
guess one of my favorite my favorite
actually my favorite it's not a segment
um my favorite time of the show is the
pre-fast five like just catching up with
Jackson Claude um you know I used to
tell everyone what I was reading and now
I've been deeply silenced humbled and
silenced no we talked about on last
night's patreon how I'm feeling about
all of the commentary about yesterday's
episode discourse and the book talk even
though of course after the patreon then
all the fans came out for me
um but no it definitely gave me
something to think about and we thought
about it last night's episode so I'm not
gonna have the same conversation again
but that is my favorite segment
everything that goes down before the
Fast Five a favorite segment of mine is
of course Kelly's mindless news because
it really felt like like it was just
like Aaron thought I had one time about
Kelly Ripa and then it like came to
fruition it turns out like I was right
you know like and I one thing about me I
love being right it's honestly like
better than anything there's better than
Donuts like there's nothing better than
being proved right
um and actually it has been a while
since we did Kelly's mindless news
because
um honestly I just got fatigued by Kelly
no and we were adding like we were part
of the problem when did our episodes get
so long okay we were just talking about
this offline yesterday I love it I'm so
here for it but I feel like we used to
be really between like 45 minutes and an
hour and now we're between an hour and
hour 20. yeah what what what's going on
I think it's because we've like expanded
the pre-stories Chit Chat like making it
about ourselves because at first I think
people really used to tune into the show
just to hear like two funny girls
thoughts on other things and now like
those funny girls have become so
beautiful and interesting like I'd
actually like to hear about the funny
girls themselves as well and they can
unburden themselves right I do think
that's like the Genesis but yes we are
like averaging an hour and 15 minutes
every single day which is like so
psychotic yeah I think everybody I mean
I know everyone loves it and we it's not
even like we're trying it's really oh
naturally crazy it's so natural rally so
today's show is gonna be long because we
have the Fast Five we have tell me lies
recap and we have deer toasters and we
have the Streisand brother so you never
know when we're going to just be
distracted and overcome with strife's
love with emotion when you like say tell
me lies what do you think
I think of because of you because you
always sing tell me lies
I think it's a Fleetwood Mac song that I
only know from the Fleetwood Mac episode
of Glee I think of it all the time
because of you I'm not thinking of a
song that I know I think of this tune my
sister sings
are there like songs I mean I know there
is for me but like what songs come to
mind that you only know because of clay
that are like very well-known classic
songs but you hadn't heard of them
because you were a child uh bust your
windows was that an original no from
Glade I don't think so it's like early
episodes I bust the windows out chica
mine is that always comes to mind is
uh
oh right beside that red fire line yep
oh you're gonna let it all hang out that
Bottom Girls you make the rocking World
Go Round very appropriate our fifth and
final story today is a lot of um chit
chat about the fat phobia Taylor Swift
is being in my opinion wrongfully
accused of it's actually not the fifth
and final I think it's the second or
third fifth and finally is a tick tock
Trend that I want to get your thoughts
on that I think will spark interesting
debate about gen Z what your favorite is
my favorite favorite
um I wonder how gen Z feels about me
I I think that like if they saw you
they'd be obsessed with you and then if
they listen to the podcast they would
hate you no that's what I mean I don't
care about how they feel about my looks
like even though it's really nice too no
I think they would be like oh my she's
sickening like unique the thing about
um gen Z is like they really are looking
for like not like your standard St your
typical standard of beauty like you
really are like unique looking like you
have porcelain skin red hair
um I think they would love you and
you're very naturally beautiful you
don't wear a ton of makeup like I think
they like from an aesthetic POV gen Z
would love you and then like when they
get on here and hear you talking about
like how homework is good for them like
they would hate you you think that they
wouldn't like my POV no that's not at
all really and I think and correct me if
I'm wrong I think like you like kind of
looked down on gen Z and think they're
doing I actually not at all okay my
perception of gen Z
is very high like I feel like gen Z
might save us all that's how I feel okay
well maybe now that you've said that
they'll change your minds because I mean
I hadn't really thought about gen Z and
I feel like now they just are lumped in
with Tick Tock but like I don't think
they're one in the same they're similar
there's overlap the Venn diagram is
definitely crisscrossing but I remember
I once heard an article about gen Z like
a few years ago when people are still
trying to Define them and the references
they shared were you know Modern Family
the the sister not Ariel winter Ariel
Winter like her character she's very
like precocious and Smart Level head and
she thinks her Millennial sister is like
a big loser and like that was an example
they gave of gen Z they gave a few like
pop culture references and I was like
gen Z
okay well maybe we'll clip this and put
it on Tick Tock so that the kids can see
that you have high respect for them and
they always like our tick tocks that's
true that's true that's so true so I'm
feeling good about gen Z oh wow okay
well that settles up but not this trend
that I saw okay well we'll talk about it
in the past five that we can get into
whenever you're ready oh you know act
really quick I just had like a list of
things let me just make sure I checked
because we said right before we needed
to talk about something
I got them all yep five out of five
you're done I feel like I'm forgetting
something
but I guess not
yeah I'll get into the fast time just
because I need to recap tell me lies
okay
so without further I did it did it do
Where Are You Bruno loves his auntie
Bruno loves his auntie so much he's
gonna be for Lauren when you leave
honestly like he's gonna be more upset
about your departure than nolios yeah of
course no but like nolia is his lady
love girlfriend for sure but like I
literally like make sure he gets eat fed
walk like I'm I'm literally his
caretaker I'm like I'm already sad for
him but I'm not going anywhere and when
I when I do leave I am coming back
imminently imminently okay fine so
without now further Ado to do about the
do Brothers here are the past five
stories that you need to know
and today's episode is sponsored by
beekeepers Naturals during cold and flu
season we are doing everything we can to
make sure we stay healthy that's why
I've been using the propolis immune
support throat spray from beekeepers
Naturals because it keeps meat in
Tip-Top shape so the immune support
throat spray I'm using it non-stop when
I'm traveling to support my immune
system when it matters most one thing
about me is like I am prone to throat
issues I don't know why but like I'm
always getting like strep like I'm
always getting throat things and when I
travel obviously my immune system is a
little bit down and I'm always getting
sick after I travel so traveling with
products from beekeepers natural
especially while on tour has been a
really great little tip for me a little
travel tip call me the points girl also
a throat spray is everything of the
source and it really is is sickness
season right now there's a bunch of
things flowing around and then they
sometimes come together and you need all
the immune the support that you can get
so propolis is made by bees and it's
backed by science it was another great
day of saving the bees so B propolis
acts as the Beast medicine it contains
vitamin and vitamin B is vitamin C zinc
and over 300 beneficial compounds and
minerals that are amazing for the human
immune system propolis is the defender
of the hive and bees use it to protect
their hive from any bacteria that might
harm them it's basically the hive's
immune system so medicinal use of
propolis dates way back to like 300 BCE
in the times of Aristotle you're girly
Aristotle is thought to have coined the
word propolis which means defender of
the city which is like Greek Pro give me
a word any word and I'll show you it is
Greek propolis
Pro before police City
propolis defender of the city that was
good
um that wasn't a man like in my notes
you know it's just kind of like
improving so beekeepers natural products
are totally trustworthy they're made
with clean ingredients they're keto
paleo gluten-free natural they're third
party tested they have no artificial
colors preservatives fillers alcohol
gluten GMO pesticides and refined sugar
so today beekeepers natural is offering
you an exclusive offer when you go to
beekeepersnaturals.com toast
um or you can just enter code toast to
get 25 off your first order that's
beekeepersnaturals.com toast
b-e-e-k-e-e-p-e-r-s-n-a-t-u-r-a-l-s.com
slash toast code toast beekeepers
Naturals products are also available at
Target Whole Foods CVS and Walgreens you
can start feeling better every day set a
thank you so much mclartia you're
welcome first story Rihanna has returned
to music with a new song for black
panther wakanda forever one week after
rumors started floating that Rihanna
would be coming back to music it has
been officially confirmed Marvel Studios
announced a new song from Rihanna would
be out this Friday as part of the Black
Panther wakanda forever soundtrack the
Tweet simply included the looking eyes
emoji in the video was simply an R with
October 28 2022. this is obviously very
exciting for everyone who's like
obsessed with Rihanna's music I love
Rihanna's music I actually think her
last album anti which was um 400 years
ago is like truly a work of art that
just gets better and better and better
however I have not been waiting with
baited breath for Rihanna's music and I
feel like I've said this before like I
love the Mogul era that she's in like
Savage X Fenty Fenty Beauty like I feel
satiated by Rihanna so of course I'm
gonna listen and enjoy but I'm not like
finally like I feel like a lot of people
are I've been okay without music from
Rihanna I've been okay just because it's
not what she wants to be doing so I'm
gonna be okay with that but I think
there is something missing in culture
the landscape and that's Rihanna and so
if she wants to come back to us I think
it's best for everyone on the count of
three let's say the best Rihanna song
okay oh
oh there's so many
okay never mind then I just wanted to
say then you just wanted to say yours
okay [ __ ] better have my money oh so
because you know what a [ __ ] better
have my [ __ ] money so good and like
the way she just like like obviously
when I say it it doesn't like feel like
like cool but like when Rihanna says
it's like no no seriously [ __ ] better
have her [ __ ] money you know yeah
like I'm like if I'm that [ __ ] I'm
quaking you know because she's so
sickening
second I'm I'm really thrilled that
really is such a good song was that on
that was like part of like in my opinion
her musical Peak which was her most
recent album was that song on the most
recent album or was it just a single
like a DJ Khaled moment I remembered as
a single but maybe it was part of a
larger album I feel like it was part of
the album because she was like doing a
lot of music videos at the time oh my
God actually I feel like her musical
Peak not like I feel like she there is
no peek like she's kept ascending she's
still at the top and like we're waiting
to hear what's next you know what's like
a really close runner-up to the best
song
four five seconds from wildling honestly
that song was a oh it's Kanye
okay I'm still gonna listen to it that
song is so good oh how do you feel about
still listening to his music
to be honest I really haven't been like
into Kanye's music for like quite some
time so like I'm not like
Honestly though the only album from
Kanye that like I I love is the life of
Pablo
um I know like his work before that is
some of like the most critically
acclaimed honestly I don't really [ __ ]
with it and then the work after like the
Christ stuff like I was into it for like
a second but like honestly like I never
listen to it I don't think I ever
listened to Like That album in full the
only album that I really loved was tlop
the life of Pablo but even then like I
don't really listen to it that much
every now and then I'll remember the
song ultralight beam and then I'll sing
it so like I think I'll still do that
yeah it obviously won't hit the same but
four or five seconds
um is such a sickening unbelievable song
I think it's one of the best songs
released in our generation like it's so
different you know and the music video
was gorgeous I will be still [ __ ]
with that song I'm sorry and you know
what I can yeah you can you can do
whatever you want honestly like me being
forced to stop doing the things I enjoy
that's anti-semitic yeah no and then
you're just suffering more right having
my people suffered enough but the
problem for me is like on principle
um
I sure if I wanted to listen to a
kindness and I would listen to a Kanye
song but it would just like remind me
but you can't really enjoy it and I
would just be like thinking about like
Global anti-Semitism I just feel sick to
my stomach like I'm just trying to enjoy
my workout or something you know like
yeah I'm not trying to that's how I feel
about like that so it's not necessarily
like the crime itself that's like I'm
never gonna feeling music it's a the
feeling and like the reminder of the
issues and it's like I don't want to be
reminded of the issues right when I'm
just trying to bop to this box I'm just
trying to Glam myself for a fun night
out okay like but you know what for me
like the best song of the part of the
four or five seconds like is Rihanna's
part like maybe I just won't listen to
the first verse which is Kanye
but if you're cutting it out then you're
like reminding yourself again
you know I just feel like you don't want
to find a solution like for real like
you're yucking all of my arms am I yeah
I said do whatever you want no you said
well here's the problem with you still
listening to it here's the problem with
you cutting it out I didn't say the
problem with you still listening to it I
said the problem for me no and by the
way I'd probably have the same
experience but like whatever yeah
but I could still I'm still woman enough
to admit that four or five seconds is
the greatest song of all time yeah sure
yeah I don't know about like of all time
of the last like 15 years the climbs out
there but uh oh sorry toast is out there
silly me but yeah no I don't it's it's
good stuff anyway what's the story
Rihanna Friday oh yeah okay Friday but I
just want to say it I'm sure the song
will be amazing and it also has to be it
has to be there's so much pressure
um it's just been really like a
sickening kind of week for music
got Rihanna we've got Taylor Meghan
Trainor's new album came out
um so did Carly Rae Jepson so they both
came out the same night as Taylor Swift
so it just kind of sucks like two pop
girls who I think are both like super
underrated
um Meghan Trainor's in like this
comeback era and it's like mostly from
Tick Tock and the music I was telling
you about this when we were in the
kitchen the music she's been releasing
is so fire it's so good she's really
like a very talented songwriter she is
and I love this comeback era for her
like I do wish she chose a different
date because we'd all be talking about
her album more yeah and then Carly Rae
Jepson there's actually like the what do
they call themselves
I think
I saw I might be wrong about this I saw
something in Tic Tac that the Carly Rae
Jepson bands call themselves Rey r-a-e
racists no like maybe it was one person
making a joke like is that what the
fandom calls themselves I thought it was
extremely toxic and fandom name
what does Carly Rae Jepsen call her fans
gypsies okay well somebody called
themselves array cyst which I thought
was very
unique however she also released her
album and there's like a huge movement
like to get Carly to Ray Jepsen the
respect she so rightly deserves and she
was overshadowed overshadowed by Taylor
Swift but she has a song going viral and
I'm really happy for her what happened
was we reached the Moon
but lost in space I think we got there
all too soon I'm coming back for you
baby I'm coming back for you and now
people are really kind of opening
themselves up to the world of Carly Rae
great I'm happy for them but like
welcome to 2012. right like if you
um and you missed her previous albums
which were fire flames so back it up
listen to those cut to the feeling like
is one of the best songs of all time
yeah no but even her first album all
those songs are amazing yeah is that I
really really really really really woman
that sounds annoying Beyond yeah it's
always the annoying ones that go viral
yeah hello call me maybe uh no that's
actually a really good song sonically
sonically it became annoying because
everyone kept playing it but even if you
heard it today like you couldn't help
but tap your foot yeah um but I'm also
not someone who's like it's like I Knew
You Were Trouble that's like what yeah
yeah that's like sonically a good song
but like if I hear it I have to jump off
a bridge
you know
yeah are you ready for our next story I
really am James Corden has addressed
about this art gate on his show saying
his wife's food allergy was the reason
for his rude comment at the New York
City restaurant so she's allergic to
yellows of eggs and eggs but not the
yellows but not the yellows in his
monologue sure dreams uh on the lately
so he alleged that his wife was given
food she was allergic to and he
recounted the series of events he said
quote so we sit down we ordered and my
wife explained that she's a serious food
allergy so when everybody's meals came
my wife was given the food that she was
allergic to but she hadn't taken a bite
of it or anything no worries we sent it
back all was good when it came back
wrong more than once he said quote In
the Heat of the Moment I made a
sarcastic rude comment about cooking it
myself it is a comment I deeply regret I
understand the difficulties of being a
server I work shifts at restaurants for
years I have such respect and I value
anyone that does such a job and the team
at that restaurant are so great that's
why I love it there
um he thought the matter was over after
the staff brought out champagne as an
apology he said I've been walking around
thinking that I hadn't done anything
wrong right but the truth is I made a
rude comment and it was wrong it was an
unnecessary comment it was ungracious to
the server it's also an unnecessary
comment coming from like a different
like he's in the position of power not
only because he's the customer but
because he's like deeply famous
um and one thing about me is like in the
last week I've become extremely
untrustworthy of James Corden like I'm
just like not buying anything he says
really I feel like that most previous
interview he did where he was like
really dismissive of the whole thing but
now he's addressing it like he's been a
little all over the place
what I just feel like we don't know the
real James Corden what okay yes but what
part of this do you think he's lying
about because if he tells anything
untrue you know Keith McNally is going
to take to Instagram I want a doctor to
tell me if it's possible to be allergic
to yolk to be allergic to egg white but
not yolk yeah Google doesn't count so no
no no I saw like it is possible and that
and and that's why for some reason
um some people can't get certain
vaccines there's something about like
this egg allergy oh okay maybe it is
right I think it's a real thing can you
be allergic to egg white only
allergy to egg whites is most common
even though both yolks and whites can
contain proteins that cause allergies
allergy to egg whites is most common
okay well I guess that I don't think at
this stage at at this point and he's
finally addressing it I don't think he
would tell a lie okay but also like he
might put on a mask I think that this is
the situation where it's like my Truth
Versus your truth because maybe that is
how James Corden saw it and like I can
imagine like him thinking he made like a
like a offhand remark was actually
really [ __ ] rude yeah no I think some
people have no self-awareness doesn't
even realize like he's James Corden this
person is like there's a power imbalance
and
I could see how he like said something
snarky that came off much Ruder than he
intended
and now we're in this situation I but I
like I think that this version of events
like really genuinely might be might be
his truth
but what very what about what he's
saying doesn't line up with what Keith
said
the sequence of events are the same but
like how he perceived what he said and
how he acted I imagine it was much worse
using but the comment no matter how you
whatever because celebrities just in
general tend to be out of touch and I
feel like now we've kind of gotten
confirmation like James cord it's like
kind of a dick yes yes yes but Jason we
want to talk about this specific
incident because like literally Loki
this whole thing is like ruining his
life no it's not no like and I mean
people already disliked him so I think
like they're happy to continue and now
yeah but
it the comment
devoid of tone like because it could
have been said in one way or another was
I should just go and cook the food
myself yeah and that's really what made
him to keep McNally the most abusive
customer he's ever right well he could
have but that's the thing it's like did
he say man I guess I should just cook
this myself or I should bloody get in
the kitchen and cook this myself right
you know like tone intonation like it's
important and I could just see him being
like rude about it like and I don't
think that like Keith McNally would just
make some [ __ ] up even though genuinely
I know nothing about him right yeah no
the thing is the thing for me like I'm
just basing this off of like how I can
see the interaction going and like I
could see him being rude yeah no I'm
sure that he was not kind and he said
like it wasn't nice and he is sorry cool
it's just really crazy that this has
become like a worldwide story when you
boil it down to one comment I should go
and cook it myself one comment that we
know of but Keith would tell us if there
were others no like at different
restaurants oh right right no but this
story in particular is about that I
should go and cook it myself no I just
think like overall it's a part of the
story where it's like we're peeling back
the layers of James Corden yeah well
that's a separate story yeah but I just
feel like this James Horden like from
here on out like really needs to act
right because everyone's going to be
looking for like a situation to expose
him because we feel it's got to be the
nicest man in Hollywood right because we
feel like there's something off and we
need to get proof and like people are
going to be looking for that proof so he
has to give people nothing he needs to
be the kindest nicest most generous and
gracious man in all of Los Angeles and
he shouldn't leave his house never no
stay inside James yeah he's on thin ice
truly so I guess that's the end of
Balthazar gate for James Corden now that
he's addressed it yeah he had to say
something because if he didn't it would
really be like oh he just is like that
yeah so now I guess we've been given but
you still think he's like that I think
even pause
I'm like let me see if something else
happens you know to fully confirm right
because someone can have a bad moment
and I just want to say I'm not really
one of these people who like despises
James Corden no like the internet really
hates him I think every time he enters a
project he ruins a project I actually
like him I think that like his show is
the best of all the crap that's on it
late night I think he's actually funny
and has good relationships with
celebrities and like is a good
interviewer in the segments I'm sure
they're not like his ideas but I think
his show is good like I don't really
even dislike him yeah so I'm not like
just saying that because I hate him and
he's ruining the wicked movie you know I
agree
I agree are you ready for our next story
yes ma'am a little more controversy
Taylor Swift has been accused of fat
phobia prompting others to defend her
message so Taylor on Friday released a
video for anti-hero the first single off
her album midnights and the video
quickly stirred controversy due to a
scene in which the singer stands on a
scale that reads fat many people on
social media have accused the singer of
fat phobia the backlash has also
resulted in other voices coming to her
defense many of whom cite Swift's past
struggles with an eating disorder so
she's in the video she steps on the
scale and it's let me just paint a
picture for those who don't know the
concept of the music video is like the
things that keep you up at night and
clearly a big part of Taylor's you know
anxiety and things that keep her up at
night is her weight her physical
appearance so there's kind of like this
green monster on her shoulder who makes
her get on the scale she looks down at
the scale and instead of saying a number
it just says fat and then like the green
monster goes like right so that's the
concept of the video yeah and so people
are saying
um like oh Taylor's worst fear keeping
her up at night is being fat but I'm fat
is fat bad
um hear us and then also people saying
shot uh this is Dr Charlotte ORD
shocking that no one involved in the
making of Taylor Swift's music video
realized how harmful it is choose the
word fat on a weighing scale to
illustrate her battle with an Ed just
thinking about the impact on her young
fans of all body sizes hashtag that
phobia okay it is possible to appreciate
Taylor Swift in Midnight as an artist
and call her out on her blatant fat
phobia Taylor Swift should have done
better because even if that is relatable
and an intrusive thought it is damaging
and fat phobic listen to fat people when
they tell you it is okay well I'm a fat
person and everyone's going to listen to
me okay uh I literally don't care like I
just don't care and this is not because
I'm a Taylor apologist I feel like I'm
actually when it comes to Taylor like I
feel like I'm pretty rational am I not
like if this if this if some if I saw
something that like like rubbed me the
wrong way like I probably would say
something about it I'd be like low-key
and like
I'd like tiptoe around it but I would
say it I saw this I didn't even think
anything of it and then there's like
backlash I'm like oh my God what now and
I'm looking into it and I really haven't
seen an argument compelling enough for
me to believe that like she did anything
wrong
um I think it's not like the whole point
of an eating disorder like anorexia or
bulimia it's like you're so [ __ ]
fearful of being overweight that you
take these Extreme Measures that like
[ __ ] with your mental health and your
physical health just so you can be
anything but fat in this music video is
about Taylor it's about Taylor's life
Taylor's thoughts Taylor's experience
and that is her experience so you
putting your [ __ ] on that is like
Irrelevant in my opinion
I agree I like it wouldn't have ever
crossed my mind that this would be an
issue for people though now seeing you
know everybody's hot takes
um I'm not surprised yeah and I want to
say something that's like
deeply problematic and honestly like you
you could call me fat phobic after I say
that I love that for you but I am a
person who has been fat I've been thin
not in a long time but I've been there
um so I'm not unfamiliar with the
territory that comes with weight and
what it does to your health physical
mental and I just I think it's worth
saying and like I don't know if I'm a
part of the problem like I don't want to
be fat like I don't like the way I look
I don't like the way I feel I don't like
the way it limits my Mobility my ability
to run around and play with rolled like
I think it I find it very limiting and I
personally don't want to be fat so I can
relate to that sentiment is that crazy
not crazy at all I think that's very
rational I think that's something that
like and I'm not saying that being fat
is bad but personally I don't want to be
fat yeah no but I don't think that's
like a personally to you thing you know
like I don't think what you're saying is
is so crazy I think there are but I
think there's downsides like and and and
health
implications I think that there are
people who it's not just about like how
you look it's it's but I think this is
like a
for me it's a lot about how I look if
I'm being honest for sure but okay it
just is
um I think like in the fat Community
there's like two ways of thinking I
think there are people like who are fat
and like are learning to live with it
even though they don't want to be
because they're just limited in their
ability to lose weight whether it's
whatever reason and then there are
people who are confident in that and and
are healthy with it and like cool with
it and I'm really happy for those people
like I really am but like that's that
shouldn't be required of of all fat
people like
I don't want to be fat and so I think
it's great that there's a part of the
community that empowers themselves to
love themselves and but I can't and I
don't want to so like I think that's
valid too yeah I really do but I think
it's important to respect each other's
thoughts like I respect you want to stay
how you are and you love it love that
for you girly keep going you're stunning
someone else you hate the way you look
and it's because of your weight and you
want to lose weight you know what I love
that too girly I'll go to the gym with
you you know what I mean like I just
think both
uh povs are valid and I think the one
about like not liking being fat it's
often criticized and like those people
are silenced and like called fat phobic
for sure so I think what critics would
say is like well what how like Taylor's
not fat she's not been fat so is she
allowed
um to have her feet like well Taylor
is a human being so she's allowed to
feel right um Taylor's also a human
being in general everyone like when
we're talking about a certain group a
certain issue or a certain group of
things well you're not this so you're
supposed to listen to the person from
that group yeah well Taylor has been
very open about her years-long struggle
with an eating disorder I mean you can
look at pictures of her and see there
was a really long period where she was
clearly underweight and really unhealthy
and that's not a physical thing that's
like a mental thing so just because
she's not fat enough for you doesn't
mean she's not entitled to like body
dysmorphia or body thoughts about her
own body right just because it's not
valid to you doesn't mean it's not valid
to her and just because you think your
situation is worse or more relevant
doesn't mean that this human being going
through it experience doesn't exist and
is invalid like I don't agree with that
at all yeah I don't oh and keep in mind
she's also like a woman in the media so
she has 10 times more [ __ ] up problems
about her body than we do because we
don't get paparazzi and called you know
pregnant on the internet you know yeah
well some of us do but you you know what
I mean like she's still a human being
like she still is valid in her life
experience and her thoughts and just
because you don't see how it could be
because if that was me I wouldn't have
if I was Taylor I wouldn't have a single
body problem be walking around naked
it's still it's still invalidating her
experience that's [ __ ] rude like it's
rude so
I guess that's my thoughts I appreciate
that you said the women of the view were
defending Taylor do you know what they
said I was just curious because
um I feel like they would have been like
pile on yeah for sure I'll pull up what
they said there I'm just curious
overall message they said that the
critics missed the point so
they came to our defense with for
engaging with deeply personal body image
issues Sunny said they missed the point
for someone who's an artist she gets to
have agency over her Artistry she was
describing a personal experience quite
frankly it's a personal experience a lot
of women experience no matter what they
look like by the way no matter how much
they weigh yeah I've experienced it and
Men you get on the scale and you're a
perfectly normal weight and all you see
is fat all you see is oh my gosh I'm
five pounds heavier than I should be
yeah I'm just not going to get all bent
out of shape over this and I like I
think also and this is I think a problem
in pop culture but specifically like in
the Swifty fandom
um the stock we put in in other people
like I saw and I was the reason why it
reminded me that we should talk about
this because I was just scrolling Tick
Tock and I'm very much on the Swift side
of tick tock and somebody posted that
the music video that she the version she
had uploaded to not YouTube but like
another platform had this part taken out
like she's obviously in the process of
taking it out
um and someone was like I'm so glad she
did this like it's ruined my week I was
so disappointed I've been crying all
week and it's like well that's another
problem like really as human beings like
we need to do less when it comes to like
the people that we follow and engage in
our fans have been like I'm a huge
Taylor Swift fan and like if she said
something that I really hated and
disagreed with like I don't think I
would for a week be upset and be crying
about it like I would be annoyed for
sure and I'd love to talk about on the
podcast but I wouldn't I think we all
collectively like we need to calm down
and stop putting so much stake in other
people it's really not healthy like
imagine if the steaks like and the
energy that we put into Taylor like we
put into ourselves too like it's so
toxic this way of like for people that
we actually know right or like our
family like your Local Heroes what about
a teacher you know yeah no I just think
like in general the amount of energy and
like focus and attention and emotions
like fans put into their favorite
celebrities that like if and when that
favorite celebrity does something that
they don't necessarily love the way it
destroys them like that's really
unhealthy it really is not normal and I
feel like that's a huge takeaway from
this whole thing for me yeah
yeah agreed a gerd I think facts were
spoken yeah I just feel like we've
gotten to a point where like sorry no I
it's just my conclusion because I don't
want people to take anything I said out
of context because I'm still thinking it
through as I'm speaking it so I just I
just want my major takeaway to be I feel
like we've gotten to a place where like
if you're overweight by Society
standards
um
you have to like accept it
and I as a fat person don't accept that
like I I feel like if you're overweight
and you want to lose weight like that is
valid and that's okay and that's part of
the reason why like since I've been
losing weight like I don't even really
want to talk about it because it's like
I'm like a betraying my fat people do
you know what I mean yeah no and every
time we talk about it I get like [ __ ]
for it and like I'm just not in the mood
so like I'm still working through my
thoughts so I'm really not I'm not
trying to upset anyone because I feel
like this is like a triggering topic but
I just think like everyone's experience
is valid and wanting to lose weight is a
valid experience it is it's just as
valid as everyone else and I feel like
we got to a place where like you're like
the villain if you want to lose weight
yeah so that's my thoughts
great thank you and I've always felt
that way like at my
highest lowest like I've never really I
work on getting comfortable in my own
skin because I love to be a confident
girly but no matter how much I weigh
because I could see people being this
well you've recently lost weight so
that's why you're saying this no even at
my highest and my happiest I still
wanted to lose weight yeah so this is
not like a new thing I just want to say
yeah no I'm done you can turn your iPad
back on you keep turning it on and
turning it off you know um I I don't
mind turning off the next story is far
less interesting
um just something that you said made me
want to ask you a question but yeah now
I've uh
I've lost it
I did say so many interesting things you
did
so I can imagine there's tons of
questions
okay next Story the boys are being so
Good by the way this Choice Brethren
because they love the toast and they
respect their mommies they do they
respect women who work working women
they do
next up Bachelor in Paradise alums
Caitlin Miller keys and Dean unglert are
engaged I'm really that was like the
last I think like season of The Bachelor
I watched like that Bachelor in Paradise
and it was really good and I was really
happy for them and they like proved
everyone wrong and now they're engaged I
thought they would always they're kind
of like alternative like they live off
the grid I thought they would be
together forever and never like you know
give it to the patriarchy and get
married but I love this for them I love
this for them I feel like they are the
perfect example obviously you don't know
what goes on behind closed doors of
compromise you know yeah and she really
adapted to his lifestyle I feel like he
changed a lot for her and their
relationship seems really beautiful and
they've built this life for themselves
that's a blend of both of their grade
extremely different personality she's
like very social she's a pageant girl
yeah and he lived in Off the Grid on the
van you know showering once a week and
like she did it she got in the van and
she went and then they came back and
they went to parties and that was for
her like they really do you're right
it's like a perfect blend of two
different people making a life together
and making it work right and I feel like
even in their content and in their jobs
they're both influencers who are travel
influencers and so they're still doing
what he likes to do which is exploring
and seeing the world but maybe you know
in a hotel forever as opposed to the van
right but they go on all these nature
walks and it's really really nice so
great to see that they got engaged is
really beautiful they haven't confirmed
it yet but a source has confirmed to
people that they are I think it's nice
I'm really happy for them I'm really
happy for them too I was really rooting
for them on that show like I still get
all bent out of shape when like Blake
was sharing those text messages you know
that was like an iconic season of
Bachelor in Paradise it really was one
of the last good ones these two have
come out on top you'd love to see it
love wins it really does love wins so
just a reminder of the good old days of
Bachelor because I like when I see every
morning like Bachelor in Paradise is on
right now is it four hours a week
woof
thought you know the bachelor used to be
like the center of our brand the center
of our universe the center of the
universe and I just never thought there
would be a day where like it wasn't the
most relevant show on TV and then almost
just like overnight it became relevant
yeah
and I don't even know if I had to blame
one season or one person it wasn't even
a moment in time you know what I mean
yeah I'm trying to think back I feel
like a lot of people stopped watching
after Matt's season well I was all the
drama with Chris Harrison because people
were watching for Chris but I think even
before that like they were flailing like
with Claire like it was so chaotic yeah
and now to me the show might as well be
off air like that's how irrelevant it is
I wish I could see what the ratings are
but I don't understand ratings charge
and I think they do that intentionally
so that we don't know what's popular so
then we don't know like that literally
nobody watches cable yes they're
suppressing information totally not to
sound crazy or anything no no like it's
why can't you just tell me like it's
intentional in layman's terms not 18 to
35 and
0.41.0197 right yeah
um anyways happy for Dean and Kailyn
yeah are you ready for our fifth and
final Story the final story
what's the final story Theo I love you
and I love the Brew no boy
Z that's my country Theo
so crunchy it was a nice belly for
drumselson
he's like get the [ __ ] off no it's not
hurting him my hands are very dainty and
small they're so gorgeous
I missed the final story song me too
that was I lost my triangle do you have
your triangle here I have it somewhere
in the house but that was went away with
the remote episodes you know how could
we have done I can't sing together yeah
so I guess we should make the most of
our remaining episodes together which we
have quite a few of don't worry you guys
um and we should keep singing keep
singing oh I'll find the triangle our
fifth and final story is Gen Z's latest
Beauty trend
okay wait let me think because I like
I'm I'm up with the trends what is it
crying makeup this one's for the sad
girls crying is now a makeup Trend
according to tick-tockers looking like
you're on the verge of tears actually
makes some people look better and you
don't have to get emotional to achieve
the look last week makeup artist Zoe Kim
keneally posted a now viral Tick Tock
directed at the unstable girlies showing
how to achieve a sorrowful look through
makeup in the clip which has been viewed
almost three million times she creates a
redness around her eyes nose and cheeks
using powder and makes her eyes look
teary with liquid glitter eyeshadow to
finish she smudges the lips with a
combination of color and gloss then adds
some glittery gel on her face to imitate
tears
okay can I say something like not to be
like so I feel like this actually might
be something like you would say like
when you're being like you know no when
you're being like the kid who tells the
teacher like there's pop quiz and this
is just like a silly Trend so like maybe
I'm looking too much into it but I feel
like isn't this like literally the
definition of like glamorizing like
sadness and tragedy like I feel like
should we be encouraging kids to like
reach out for help and like to talk
about their feelings and not like become
obsessed with being sad like maybe I'm
really looking too much into this or not
this is your serving Trend right like
again being sad is not a state that we
want to remain in no and it's like of
course it's a part of life but like to
glamorize the low parts of life and
encourage young people to stay in that
thing sadness whereas like shouldn't you
know as older people and just like
people who've lived shouldn't we be
encouraging the Young Generation like
yes sadness is a part of life like
there's nothing you can do to avoid it
but like lean on your friends and family
talk to someone go to a counselor like
it gets better right like this is like
kind of weird no I I find it disturbing
because it's not even just like if
you're feeling sad do your makeup and
feel better no no it's not even if
you're feeling sad wear sad makeup and
make looking sad is nice it's like well
so happy people will now start to look
sad and that's and that's just like the
vibe and I feel like hopefully gen Z
turned off the podcast at this point
because it got so long but I feel like
the Zeitgeist is so sad like you you
look at the music that kids are
listening to and it's so depressing
everything is depressing and everything
is just like okay but it defensive gen Z
the music we were listening to not just
gen z i because I think it's Millennial
music too we're all listening to the
same music the music on the radio it's
just like
it's of course people experience sadness
you write about sad things but I feel
like no one wants to find an exit
strategy for their sadness like we're
all away and I think that's an a not a
great thing I think we should strive for
happiness yeah you know yeah sadness
can't be avoided sometimes but we don't
need to stay here no I agree it's it's
and when it's all the music listen like
if you're a um
neutral if you're feeling neutrally not
happy nor sad but all the music on the
radio and and your playlist that your
friends are sharing with you is all like
this music that's bringing you down in
turn you will be brought out you will be
brought down yeah no I think like
there's definitely and it's a
generational thing I feel like the
younger kids are just like leaning into
like sadness and
sorrow and like Blues
um and it's weird but then I also think
about like when we were kids like you
know we were listening like tonight will
be the night that I will fall for you
like really emo like we were like the
Emo music How to Save a Life like kill
me I I mean maybe you know older people
were like these kids are so emotional
with the emo but
but separately the kids are not okay and
like you see statistics about how kids
are doing right now and like especially
with social media like suicide yeah uh
kids feeling alienated and like
especially girls and what especially
with the pandemic and it's like we need
to be helping them out of them
I forgot that they're growing up in the
digital age they forgot like the reality
of what's happening on the ground right
the social dilemma that those statistics
about like young girls on social media
like comparing themselves like I think
is what was it it was like one in ten
like young teen now I'm not gonna watch
this statistic but it was like a suicide
statistic more more affecting teenage
girls because on social media they're
constantly comparing themselves to
others
um and it's like the kids are not okay
and it's because social media plays a
huge part of it and like the destruction
of their mental health right and I feel
like it should be the role of Hollywood
and and influences and influencers to
help the kids you know and like be
positive influences yeah and there's no
real positive influences for positivity
there is Jojo siwa and she shouldn't say
she's gonna she might save the kids I
don't know what the content she's
putting out is she's just always dancing
with bows in her hair and rainbows on
her face and sparkling and looking cute
and running around and only hanging out
with like appropriate influencer she
doesn't do anything nefarious nothing
sexy like she is literally the to a t a
good role model like actually I'm
actually I think often about how I'm
happy for the kids that they have JoJo
okay but we need more people of course
also like older people and and no
offense to Jojo
like I love what you felt like I hope
you're a chain smoking cigarettes
we need cooler people too I'm sorry
actually JoJo's he was is becoming
pretty cool she's not what you think she
is I mean she's an adult she's in a
relationship now she came out like she's
much more grown she still dances around
like a teenager with sparkles in her
hair but um she's not the JoJo that you
remember she's really evolved in the
last two years I think she turned 18.
like she's more mature she's still not
like overly mature she's still like an
age-appropriate role model for like
teenagers and young prepubescent teens
but she's getting cooler She Wears Gucci
like a lot well then she actually wears
like a ton of Gucci that's she's so rich
too pretty cool look into JoJo you're
gonna like what you see okay but we need
more JoJo's you know yes of course
influence is overwhelmingly
depressing no it's videos of themselves
crying and there's obviously like
there's nothing wrong with you know
going through a bad period of course not
it's like anxiety but I I feel like we
should be helping the kids to
come out of it right not to meet them
where they are to understand that it's a
part of life it's not life it's just a
part of life yeah no I agree so that's a
weird trend for sure like I would I
raise my eyebrows at it as well yeah
especially like I mean I guess I look
kind of cute when I cry like I look
busted you know how everyone like takes
pictures of themselves when they cry
it's just such a weird thing like I
definitely do it sometimes but yeah it's
such a weird thing everyone doesn't do
it sometimes for sure like I'm just
curious what I look at
there should there's definitely like a
psychological study on like why people
do that yeah it's really weird
yeah
then like also like people video
themselves like they just leave their
phone in the corner when they're having
like a true [ __ ] mental breakdown and
like that is like a little weird to me
honestly like I just saw a video like of
a issue went viral and like people were
reaching out like you're gonna be fine
she had like a full-blown mental
breakdown like her boyfriend was like
you know calming her down rubbing her
back like saying positive words she
filmed it yeah and they filmed it like
that first the comments were like oh man
that's so sweet he's such a good
boyfriend and then like a couple people
and then it became like I think it's
like so you're having this like mental
[ __ ] breakdown like what possessed
you to like prop your phone up and put
the light on to like get a video like it
was bizarre yeah and then and then it
makes me feel like that wasn't a genuine
breakdown wait and not even just prop
your phone up like maybe you want to
watch it back one day like remember this
dark place that you were in but then
also posting it yeah no it's and also I
just don't know where to draw the line
between like being genuine and authentic
and transparent on the internet but then
also like being a little contrived being
a little contrived and also like I do
think that there are things that should
be for yourself uh I agree with that
completely
um so those were the past five let's
dive into our TV recap because I know
you're dying to talk about tell me lies
and it is to you by match the dating app
do you
let me ask you a question are you sorry
do you do you I do do me match the
dating app is pretty hot and bothered
about this topic because understandably
it's a juicy one match believes that the
most important relationship you have is
with yourself so in a world where you
can choose to do anything or anyone
Choose Yourself first because dating
someone who knows what they want and
won't set up for Less that is sexy as
hell so if you're over some of the men
in your life who are just like not or
women sorry not me being heteronormative
if you're over like the people in your
life who are either not treating you
right not a good match not compatible
whatever the reason is here are
some alternatives for people who really
just might be more beneficial to your
life like you can be with your own best
you could be your own best friend you
know who's better than me
should I go on a date with smelly Joe or
should I go on a date with me with
mincardia with mcclurgia
um so you can take yourself out to
dinner take yourself home if the
conversation isn't stimulating you can
stimulate yourself if they're the
ghosting type be your own boo their
boring stories don't have an off switch
or three different intensity settings if
they're only hot and you're only
bothered make yourself hot and bothered
so if you do you you already know the
best relationships show up when you show
up for yourself first there's never been
a better time to try match download the
match app today I know we have a ton of
listeners and just people I know in my
life who've had so much success with the
match app and I love that match really
encourages you guys to like I I feel
really strongly like you shouldn't put
yourself out there unless you are
comfortable with yourself and that means
like really knowing who you are what you
want and like taking care of yourself
first and match totally endorses that so
before you get on Match and start
meeting great people make sure that like
you yourself are in the right place and
like you feel like you're at a you know
a point in your life where you can
really give yourself to someone because
if you can't love yourself in the words
of RuPaul how the hell are you gonna
love anybody else thank you mclartia
um
tell me lies okay this segment will be
full of spoilers of the season finale
and the whole season starting now what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I honestly like I
don't want to be so negative but like I
didn't really understand why the last
maybe four episodes were big nothing
burgers and then they just like shoved
so much random [ __ ] in this one episode
it was like it was like they ran out of
time or something like it felt so weird
I know and I felt like we were gonna
actually have all the answers in one
episode episode because we were getting
to a lot of places also the biggest
answer or thing that I got from this
episode is Lucy is the villain of this
show yes she starts as a protagonist but
I think that might be like the twist of
the book is that she is the worst person
on the show and you think it's Stephen
because obviously you think it's Pippa
even you think it's yeah pip is like
okay I don't want to be friends with him
but Pippa is my queen and my I'm just a
little Pippa and my God is Diana like
Diana Jackie was screaming when they
walked down the stairs together we
watched together screaming every scene
Diana came in last night first at the
coffee shop where she's just sucking
Slaughters them didn't even have to do
anything just showed how [ __ ] losery
out on your trip to India and then
you're gonna do literally nothing all
summer just so you could you know hope
to hang out with your boyfriend who's
mean to oh cool loser loserville
population you no ambition like oh and
Diana's going to work at a premium law
office right and she would have helped
Steven get there and you're helping
Steven go nowhere even though in his
heart of heart Stephen wants to better
himself right and obviously Steven is a
psychopath I mean he literally killed
Mason left her there right you called
that I did he is a very bad person of
course and so and I love that that was
the last thing Macy said to him she's
like you're literally like a bad person
right and so up until last night's
episode I thought he was the worst
person on the show but the worst person
is Lucy because she masquerades as a
good person I think she thinks she's a
good person whereas Steven like I think
knows he's a psychopath and it's like
when the psychopath is scared of you no
she's like a horrible friend too and now
I loved him he finally went back to the
wedding because we had like so much
context and she slept with heaven like
no listen goodbye good day I mean I'm
glad that it didn't derail him still
marrying Brie I don't know if Bree knows
but it's really inconsequential at this
point right I know like she ruined
pippa's relationship she ruined
Wrigley's life and is lying about it I
would never yeah diabolical diabolical
um she's a terrible friend she's so like
self-centered
um and she's so not self-aware because
like anyone who has an ounce of
self-awareness but like really it's not
really Steven isn't really hiding the
fact that he's not like he doesn't love
her he's just afraid of her now because
he happened to have told you this
information which was obviously the
biggest regret of his life because he
should be with Diane and his life would
be back on track and he wouldn't be
getting an A minus and not getting an
internship for the summer if it weren't
for Lucy right and if he doesn't have an
internship this summer before his senior
year like getting a job after a senior
year will be even harder his prospects
will be smaller and he is already like
starting from behind right you know
because he doesn't have like connections
like everyone else yeah
um she's just the worst and like when
they walk down the stairs I was like I
was
sure I thought she was obviously going
to walk in and then hooking up it was
more of the same but when he just
unilaterally decided that like he was
[ __ ] done with her right like I'm
breaking up with you and I'm not even
gonna tell you
and in two [ __ ] seconds Diana swoops
in and steals her man's back like
obviously I think Diana can do much
better and I'm glad to see that in the
five years later they're not together
but whatever Diana wants I want okay I
need a spin-off about Diana Diana Summer
Diana's life tell me Diana what does
Diana think tell Diana lies I am
obsessed with her okay but then um I
agree I'm glad it wasn't her who ended
up being engaged to Stephen five years
later however
um I really wish that they had put Lydia
in Lydia is
Lucy's friend from home and when Lucy
called her to like hang out I wish she
had just like shown her face and been
like oh sorry I can't hang out because
when she showed up at the pool and was
engaged to Stephen I'm like who is this
[ __ ] yeah I just they showed her in uh
in the before so she was talking she
needed to be in the episode yeah I
wonder how those two get together right
so now it's like there will be a second
season I I don't imagine it's not being
greenlit like everyone is watching the
show are you gonna read the book or no
wait no I just like it like a TV she
likes the book because it's apparently
really different but I I literally need
to know like I actually please no one
spoil it for me but like I'd want
someone to tell me what the [ __ ]
happened and by the way we were both
under the impression that like Drew died
because at the wedding he was like
yesterday was his brother's birthday
right be cool don't be so hard on him
um
so we still don't have any Clarity
because kind of the whole season I was
waiting for Drew to like like overdose
or something because he was so depressed
and I I thought we knew already that he
had died right but maybe he's not maybe
he's not maybe him and Wrigley just
haven't spoken in six years he's in a
coma yesterday was the birthday right
and that's hard for Wrigley I feel so
bad for Wrigley like me too he's a p
John he's like annoying but he's a pig
Lucy and Steven ruined his life and he's
a good person and really him and Pippa
even though she like wasn't into him as
much as he was into her they were a nice
couple they were and even though I don't
think she was in love with him like he
was with her like she really cares about
him you know yeah
yeah and she didn't do the [ __ ] that
she's being accused of like if he wanted
to be mad at her for like hooking up
with another girl sure like but she's
not lying and I just need Lucy to go
down I need her to go down fast at the
end of the day she's framed but I don't
really think she goes down because if
she was like she wouldn't be invited to
this wedding right but we saw in episode
one there is this weird tension between
her and Pippa and when she pulls up to
the wedding it's like she doesn't want
to be there she didn't even bring her
boyfriend like I do think she's on the
outs with the group and of course in
episode one I was like why are all these
wenches being mean to Lucy and it's like
oh no they're probably all like Lucy has
to come they weren't mean enough they
weren't mean enough she really is like
so stunning like it's insane she is but
you know her insides are for me I hate
that face now I'm inhaling this woman
yeah hating no I'm hating as well and
like when she put her mom through and
it's like I think Stephen by the way I
tell me one thing her mom did wrong
that she had an affair wasn't an affair
their dad was dying right the sun Affair
honestly I'm sure if the dad knew he
would have been like yeah please like go
knowing she like keeps telling the story
and everyone has such a big reaction I
don't think I get that crazy I don't
think it's that crazy no it definitely
like would be weird and it would take me
a little while to like get over it but
five years later I'm telling everybody
about it in college like calm down yeah
that's your and she really is like so
privileged and I think that's why
everyone resents her like she like
that's your biggest trauma like my God
you know what other people go through in
their life right not to minimize
anyone's trauma no but also she's so not
driven like she's really just like
wasting her time in school like and just
floundering through the whole thing in
that class not getting a summer job
right not even going to India which she
talked about all year like it's so
biometrically opposed to Diana my queen
Diane and like ambitious Queen ambitious
Queen is gonna be on the Supreme Court
like I can't wait
um so it was a really good show we do
have to wait to see if they get
Greenland so be a while before we find
out which I know is going to be tough
for you I like I don't know what to do I
think reading the book
I guess I'll get to the end but it will
it will I won't enjoy it so I don't know
what to do um do you want to do to your
toasters or should we move it to
tomorrow because I feel like we have
nothing to talk about tomorrow oh no
actually there's so much TV
and Salt Lake City all right so let's
eat your toaster so I was just thinking
we're ready at an hour but I guess we're
going along today all right dear
toasters Our advice segment where you
can write in deertoesters gmail.com we
will always keep your [ __ ] Anonymous and
you could write in about anything that
you're going through so let's help our
girlies out today what do you say Jax
I say yes I'm still thinking about tell
me lies though like it's got me all
messed up dear beautiful standing in
smart Queens I'll make this short my
father-in-law got married last year to a
woman who's only four years older than
my husband and I they not only got
married at the same wedding venue as us
three years later but now they're
expecting a baby the same month that my
son was born he'll just have turned one
by the time their baby is born and he
will have an uncle that is younger than
him I'm not sure if I should feel I'm
not sure if I should feel offended that
this
that both my wedding venue and my baby's
birth month has been taken for me help
me sort this out
um you're stretching a little bit on the
birth month you can't call a month no
you can't and I did think at first it
was like they are both do at the same
time which would be complicated but you
know what it's his life
and sure the wedding venue thing I guess
is like a little weird but really what
does it matter yeah like if he's happy
and she's you know makes him happy and
they have a new family like Let Him Live
Life yeah I mean is she a wench like do
you like her on a personal level like or
are you just looking for things to
dislike because with the birthday come
on its face it's like it's conventional
yeah but
is she a good girl is she a good mom is
she a good aunt is she good step mommy
like yeah it sounds like you maybe just
like don't like her so you're looking
for things like to call her out on like
she took my birth month no or that like
you think that it should be weird so
you're insisting that it is you know but
I think that it could be nice no same
venue is definitely weird okay maybe
it's a small town and there's one big
bad venue in town right that's the
nicest yeah one Hall yeah that like is
the nicest it's possible but that that I
could see like that's not a reach like
it's bizarre yeah it's a little bizarre
but like as far as him having a younger
Uncle it treated like a cousin and it's
a young girl a yet uncle
um it's nice for the kids yeah that's
true it's unconventional but like at
this point they're married so you might
as well just like lean in and start
it's like a friend you know yeah
yeah I mean you can make the most of it
if you want to and I would encourage you
to do that because it's life life is
long yeah it's family and as long as no
one's doing anything like obvi like
particularly nefarious it's just
unconventional but but convention
yeah using butt convention buck buck
convention Yes sounds like a conference
that a lot of bucks go to
hahaha
action 2022 coming to a town near you
that's funny hey Jackson Claude I have
the most beautiful stunning and smart
friend she's really unmatched however
she has now been dating a loser for the
past year and I need some advice on how
or if I should say something she hid
this relationship for me and her mom who
she's super close with for almost four
months and I think she did so because
she knew we would disapprove of him
right away and we did my first
experience with him was watching him get
into a bar fight in which he was the one
in the wrong and he ended up breaking
his hand so it wasn't just a quick
little tiff it was quite a lot there
were a few other awkward disappointing
encounters after that but my husband
encouraged me to give him one more
chance because she's so important to me
the last chance I gave him ended with
him being a drunk and immature [ __ ]
jumping on top of a stranger stranger's
car going through a drive-through with
people in the car I wanted to die of
embarrassment my best friend deserves
the world she is so much ahead of her
and this guy is really dragging her down
it's hard for me to want to defend her
in her relationship when people ask me
why she's with him I'm scared to say
something to her and have her shut me
out because in the past she's gotten
defensive of little comments I've made
but I can't keep watching her waste her
time and reputation on him what would
you do like it sounds like like
they're just some people
who like
make bad choices when it comes to
romance and like they don't want to be
helped and it's like frustrating to be
their friend and want to help but I just
feel like you have to let people like be
miserable on their own do you know what
I mean and learn for themselves like I
always think you know issuing a warning
won't just if I saw some guy I was
dating get out of his car in a drive
through it wasted jump on someone's car
I would be so mortified because I'm a
normal human being right and some people
just don't have that receptor so it
takes them a really bad something really
bad to happen for them to open their
eyes like okay I think you say your
piece and then you let her make her own
choices the only thing is it will
inevitably affect your friendship
because if it were me like I don't want
to be around that person I don't want to
be around that guy so I'll hang out with
you we can get our nails done whatever
but all these like couply things that we
would be doing we're not going to be
doing yeah and yes your friendship will
be affected but that is her choosing him
over you which is her choice to make
yeah and there might come a time where
they're no longer together and she'll
come crawling back and you're a good
friend so you'll let her in
um and then this like I feel like with
people like this it's just a cycle like
yeah they have to learn for themselves
there's no telling someone I know and
it's like you you then just become the
villain by saying something even though
you're coming from a genuine POV like
you you just become the villain because
you're saying something like they don't
want to hear you're a naysayer right I
think that if you're genuinely concerned
you should say something because
you don't like yeah I think that's your
responsibility as a friend to just like
also it starts to plan in her head like
my friends and my family don't like him
maybe that's something to think about
again to her thinking everything's about
like the next time she gets mad at him
like now she also has in her brain like
wow Sarah doesn't approve of him or
whatever this girl's name is right so
just let her know how you feel and then
you've got to step away and let the
chips fall where they may like at some
point like we're not in college anymore
like we're all growing up like you have
a marriage like you need to take care of
your marriage you can't be like fixing
her relationship it's her life and it's
her choices and it's her mistakes to
make yeah all right third and final is a
little bit lighter hello Jackson Claude
hope you're having a great week together
let's get into it I think we are having
a great week obvious we're going to the
grocery store after this I can't wait
I'm getting married this Summer to the
most amazing man he's got everything
kind humble he's the most loving partner
I could ask for he also has an
interesting mustache handlebars literal
twists on the side of his face that he
just thinks are hysterical mostly I just
deal with this odd choice and cringe
when strangers compliment it but I'm
really not thrilled with the idea that
he will that he will have this punch
line on his face for our wedding I mean
those pictures last forever any
reasoning I use to try to convince him
to shave them off is met with but I've
never felt more me what is a girl
supposed to say to that any advice on
how to lovingly steer him in a different
direction from a Lucky in Love except
for the mustache maybe it's just me but
like I only care what I look like in the
picture it's such a good place like I
don't even look at the other person's in
the pictures when it's like my wedding
pictures no I mean I've looked at my
wedding pictures a thousand times and if
you had told me like Tom Selleck was
standing next to me I'd believe you
because I've never looked a bun right
and it's like and then eventually when
they're hanging on the wall one day like
only he's gonna have I have an idea
Photoshop no I have an idea is it to
photoshop no I have an idea I have the
idea okay it's such a long day what do
you wake up at six to start taking
photos
once you guys are dressed do a ton of
photos with the mustache
then shave it before the wedding and
take more pictures that's a good idea I
think for him it's not that he wants
photos with his mustaches that he wants
to be a mustachioed man bring my idea up
to him like for real sure that's a good
idea
so
I it's hard to relate because I don't
know how much this would bother me oh it
would bother me like you know Ben and
his facial hair remember during the
pandemic when he had a beard like yeah
and and now I look back and I hated it
then and I look back and I [ __ ] hate
it so then what would you do see the
thing with me is like I'm a [ __ ] Naggy
wife and like I get what I want and this
winter break I want Jordan so like I I
would get my way because I'm a bulldog
like you know what I do I take the razor
and like cut a thing like a piece of the
beard off so we'd have to to like I put
him in a position where he looked more
stupid with it on like take a pair of
scissors when he's sleeping and cut off
one of the handlebars he can't go one
handlebar he's gonna be like all right I
guess I'll just shape the whole thing
but is that a way to like start a
marriage what if he like was like oh
you're crazy well I don't think a way to
start a marriage as a husband not
listening to a wife so now we're even
but it's his body his choice no it's not
it's not no when you get married it's
not your body only for the man though
like my body my choice Ben's body my
choice okay
but they're not married yet even when we
were engaged
it was your choice it's my body but you
didn't do anything about the beard in
the pandemic I mean it was so hard to
like scrounge up an ounce of like give a
[ __ ] during the pandemic like about
anything I didn't care about anything
enough in the pandemic to do anything
you know what I mean yeah yeah like it
was just it was giving low energy I feel
you okay so
I always keep working it you know keep
dropping hints yeah you could be
aggressive as Claudia has said I gave
two good ideas either chop one of the
handlebars off or have him agree to
shave it for the wedding but you'll get
a ton of pictures before with it on yeah
that's a that's a good compromise I
would my advice would be trying to make
peace with it you know
it's weird it yeah I mean it's not for
me no and it's like but it doesn't
really have it when you guys met yeah
what is the Genesis of the mustache
that's what I want to know yeah
best of luck out of all these options do
the one that feels most in tune with you
I feel like the one shaving it the day
of the wedding after pictures is
probably the best one that's like that's
called compromise this is a wedding like
people have to compromise in a marriage
yeah
um so thinking everyone who wrote in
dear toasters gmail.com every Wednesday
we will read your quandries on air and
we will do our best to help you and keep
them Anonymous of course so don't worry
about that that is our show thank you so
much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that Spotify
iTunes Stitch your public video
iheartradiocastbox all the places where
we listen to podcast finding dust the
morning just leave a five star you sound
like um
what is that
I don't know leave a five-star review
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are goodbye have a great day guys love
you bye